la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
intégral de la séance du mercredi 18
octobre a été publié sur le site
internet du Sénat il n'y a pas
l'observation le procès-verbal est donc
adopté mes chers collègues par lettre en
date du 17 octobre la commission des
lois demande au Sénat en application de
l'article le 5 TER de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires de lui
conférer les prérogatives attribuées aux
commissions d'enquête pour une durée de
6 mois afin de mener sa mission
d'information sur les émeutes survenus à
comptter du 27 juin
2023 la conférence des président
examinera cette demande lors de sa
réunion du mardi 31 octobre
prochain l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale après
engagement de la procédure accélérée
relative aux services express régionaux
métropolitains dans la discussion
générale la parole est à monsieur
Clément baunne ministre chargé des
transports
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
président de commission monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très heureux d'être
devant vous aujourd'hui pour l'examen de
cette proposition de loi qui porte un
grand projet de transformation de nos
mobilités dans tous les territoires de
France pour les années à venir c'est
c'est à ce titre je le sais un texte
attendu par la Chambre des territoires
qui le Sénat tout particulièrement je
tiens ici tout d'abord à remercier
l'auteur du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale le député et président de
commission Jean-Marc zoulzi qui s'est
saisi de ce sujet majeur il y a quelques
mois pour son soutien sans faille ainsi
bien sûr que monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le sénateur philippe Tabarot
pour le travail très important que vous
avez réalisé sur ce texte dans des délis
contraints après le dernier scrutin les
services express régionaux et
métropolitains les CERMES comme on les
appellera peut-être ont vocation à
traduire pleinement l'ambition que porte
le gouvernement et je sais grand nombre
d'entre vous en faveur de la
transformation de nos transports la
décarbonation le report modal vers le
rail la priorité au transport du
quotidien qui sont au cœur de notre
action et au cœur de cette proposition
de loi au fond il s'agit d'offrir des
solutions de décarbonation plutôt que
des punitions ou des restrictions tous
ces éléments se trouvent en effit
rassemblé dans le projet des CERMES tel
que nous le concevons et tel qu'il
commence déjà à se déployer avec
certaines métropoles et régions
pionnières je pense évidemment à la
métropole de Strasbourg et à la région
du Grand Est pour permettre ce
déploiement nous avons voulu mobiliser
deux acteurs reconnus complémentaires
que sont SNCF réseau et la Société du
Grand Paris de les mettre ensemble de
manière innovante au service des
collectivités et des territoires
volontaires comme cela a été envisagé
par le Conseil d'orentation des
infrastructures don je veux saluer
encore la qualité du rapport et du
travail qui a mobilisé plusieurs d'entre
vous comme à l'Assemblée nationale ces
deux acteurs ont en effet vocation à
travailler main dans la main pour
conduire le dialogue avec les
territoires concernés métropole et
région premier chef en vue de la
réalisation de ces projets nouveaux
c'est ce à quoi nous avons commencé à
travailler c'est ce que permettra de
manière claire organisée structurer la
proposition de loi qui vous est
présentée aujourd'hui en effet la
question de cette mobilisation commune
pour mener à bien ce grand chantier
nécessite des adaptations législatives
celle que propose le texte issu de
l'Assemblée nationale est déjà amandé
par vous mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en commission nous semble
aller dans le bon sens et je sais que la
suite de la discussion parlementaire
aboutira à mieux en définir les
modalités cette mobilisation a vocation
à s'inscrire dans un cadre qui définit
notamment et c'était attendu sur le plan
politique et juridique l'objet lui-même
de ces services express régionaux
métropolitains il faut garder ici à
l'esprit que pour important qu'il soit
les CERMES ne seront pas la réponse à
tous les besoins d'aménagement et de
mobilité dans No territoire j'entends
donc les appels à intégré beaucoup de
modes de transport possibles voir tous
les modes de transport possibles mais
ces projets doivent aussi être vu comme
une brique comme un élément et non comme
l'alpha et l'oméga d'une politique
d'ensemble en faveur de la mobilité des
transport du quotidien de la
décarbonation que l'État et les
collectivités doivent mener
conjointement c'est un élément essentiel
de notre politique de transport ça n'est
pas un élément évidemment exclusif s'il
est important de bien définir l'objet il
est tout aussi important que le cadre
que donne cette proposition de loi
demeure assez souple que ce soit un
cadre de flexibilité d'adaptation au
territoire et de confiance dans les
collectivités afin qu'il puissent
s'adapter aux réalités forcément
spécifiques de chacun des territoires
concernés cette loi est une loi de
liberté j'espère qu'elle deviendra loi
dans quelques semaines est une loi
d'adapt à chaque territoire et je crois
que nous devons garder aussi cet état
d'esprit ce sont les collectivités
concernées qui devront porter et
remonter si je puis le dire des projet
qui seront évidemment au terme de ce
texte tel qu'il est aujourd'hui proposé
validé par l'État cofinancé par l'État
et défin ensuite de manière conjointe et
cohérente pour le gouvernement nous
devons prendre pour point de départ les
demandes du terrain c'est l'esprit de ce
texte c'est l'esprit de ce projet tout
entier le texte garantit par ailleurs la
mise en place de l'ensemble et c'est
essentiel des ressources sour
financières nécessaires en matière
d'investissement en priorité pour
permettre la réalisation de ces services
express régionaux métropolitains là
aussi en pleine concertation avec les
territoires et en différenciant les
solutions d'une métropole ou d'une
région à l'autre concernant la question
largement du financement des CERMES qui
je le sais a soulevé beaucoup de débats
au cours des dernières semaines parfois
quelques polémique mais surtout des
interrogations je souhaitais apporter
d'emblé ici quelques clarifications qui
je l' pourront vous rassurer et nous
faire ensemble avancer d'une part l'État
a d'ors et déjà prévu des sommes
importantes près de 800 millions de
crédit dédiés aux services express
régionaux métropolitains dans les
prochains contrats de plan ettat région
qui sont comme vous le savez en
discussion région par région c'est une
somme qui est très loin d'être
négligeable ça n'est pas un premier euro
symbolique puisque nous partions dans la
génération précédente de zéro c'est un
projet nouveau pour lequel l'État
mobilise en entrée de négociation une
somme déjà extrêmement importante et
pour pour lequel il est important que
les collectivités notamment les régions
puissent mobiliser au moins les mêmes
sommes c'est une somme qui est consacrée
à l'investissement sur une période la
période de ces volets mobilité
2023-227 et qui n'ont pas la fin de
l'histoire et la totalité d' l'histoire
du financement des investissements dans
les CERMES c'est par ailleurs une somme
qui a nécessairement un caractère
indicatif à ce stade puisque ni le
montant exact des projets ni leur
calendrier précis de déploiement ne sont
aujourd'hui connus ils seront sont
affiné notamment sur la base de ce texte
que j'espère devenir loi rapidement pour
ensuite préciser les plans
d'investissement les plans de
financement et les ressources mobilisées
pour le dire clairement l'état met une
somme importante sur la table il attend
que les régions puissent mobiliser des
sommes analogues et bien sûr nous irons
ensemble plus loin pour assurer dans la
durée le financement de ces
investissements il est clair qu'entre
2023 et 2027 pour certains projets en
tout cas qui sont aujourd'hui moins
avancés que d'autres et qui nécessitent
des travaux étude ce seront
principalement ces études approfondies
que nous financerons dans un premier
temps et les premiers travaux c'est très
important je crois de préciser qu'il ne
s'agit donc pas d'un financement
exhaustif et définitif de la part de
l'État je n'ai par ailleurs par ailleurs
pardon pas fait mystère de ma volonté de
disposer pour les années à venir avec
vous d'une véritable programmation
financière pour les infrastructures de
transport dans lesquels ces services
trouvent naturellement leur place c'est
je crois d'ailleurs demandé par beaucoup
d'entre vous avec qui j'ai eu groupe par
groupe la chance d'échanger que je
continuerai
à ce que je continuerai pardon à faire
dans les prochaines semaines le
financement des CERMES je le redis doit
être partie intégrante de cette
visibilité pluriannuelle quel qu'en soi
les modalités il y a donc déjà et il
continuera à y avoir des financements et
notamment des financements de l'État
pour les CMEs dans leur phase
d'investissement en premier lieu et le
cas échéant je crois que c'est aussi une
des avancées importantes que propose ce
texte de loi des financements innovant
tels que des recettes affectées au
projet peuvent et doivent pouvoir être
utilisé l'un des actes forts de ce texte
est en effet de permettre la création de
sociétés de projets mon le rapporteur
qui pourront là encore si les
collectivités le souhaitent au cas par
cas mettre en place une fiscalité locale
spécifique adaptée et affectée
spécifiquement à ce projet en s'appuyant
sur une dette maîtrisée qui là encore
offre une faculté ne propose pas une
obligation mais fait partie de cette
boîte à outil du financement des
investissements dans les services
express régionaux métropolitains qui est
absolument essentiel vous le savez comme
je le pense profondément ce modèle a
fait ses preuves mutatis mutandis sur le
Grand Paris Express et le gouvernement
l'a déployé pour les projets de ligne à
grande vitesse en cours grâce d'ailleurs
à des amendements du Sénat dans le PLF
pour
2023 ce mode de financement a plusieurs
grands avantages celui d'offrir une
grande stabilité du financement une
gouvernance spécifique et une mission
dédiée notamment une maîtrise d'ouvrage
dédié qui sont propices à la bonne
réalisation et à l'accélération de ces
projets je crois qu'à cet égard
l'expertise développée la mission
déployée par la Société du Grand Paris
sont exemplaires je sais que nous
débattrons dans quelques minutes de
certains points qui le mérite encore
c'est l'intérêt de notre débat de cet
après-midi le gouvernement notamment est
favorable à ce que la priorité du
ferroviaire soit clairement affirmé
clairement lisible dans la définition de
ces services express régionaux
métropolitains et que ces service
demeure centré sur les transports de
voyageurs plus que de marchandises ou
encore que la question du tarif des des
péages ferroviaires essentiel vous
connaissez mon engagement à cet égard
fasse l'objet d'une réflexion spécifique
qui puisse faire l'objet d'un amendement
j'espère consensuel ou de compromis que
je présenterai dans quelques instants en
outre le gouvernement a également déposé
un amendement pour relever le plafond de
dette auquel est soumise la Société du
Grand Paris ce qui est essentiel par
souci de cohérence pour que celle-ci
puisse remplir ses ses missions ces
discussions pour importante qu'elle soit
ne saurait remettre en cause le fait que
nous rejoignions très largement sur les
principes sur le contenu sur les
modalités retracées dans la proposition
de loi telle qu'amendé d'ors et déjà en
commission je vous remercie très
sincèrement pour ce travail rapide
sérieux engagé dans un esprit
constructif pardelà les sensibilités
politiques vous l'aurez compris en un
mot le soutien le gouvernement soutient
pleinement ce texte nous aurons
l'occasion de discuter de certains
amendements mais son esprit et son
contenu sont clairs sa nécessité est
avérée et je crois qu'au-delà d'aspects
d'acronymes qui peuvent paraître parfois
technique comme nos services express
régionaux métropolitains c'est une
grande ambition et une grande avancée
que porte cette proposition de loi
j'espère qu'elle pourra ainsi recueillir
une très large majorité je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre la
parole est maintenant à philippe Tabarot
rapporteur de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable et ce pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président longjot
mes chers collègues je suis heureux de
vous retrouver aujourd'hui pour examiner
la proposition de loi relative au
services express régionaux métropolitain
qui a fait l'objet d'un travail
approfondi en commission et ce dans un
esprit transpartisant comme vous le
savez l'objectif de déployer 10 RER
métropolitains qui sont depuis lors
devenus des serermes résulte d'une
annonce du président de la République en
novembre dernier confirmé quelques mois
plus tard par la première ministre lors
de la présentation du plan avenir pour
les
transports or vous vous en rappelez sans
doute cette idée n'est pas complètement
neuve puisqu'elle trouve son origine
dans le rapport annexé à la loi
d'orientation des mobilités de 2019 cher
Didier Mandelli
je me réjouis qu'elle se concrétise
aujourd'hui par le biais de cette
proposition de loi j'en viens au vif du
sujet et vais à présent vous exposer les
quatre principaux axes qui ont guidé le
travail de la
commission le premier axe concerne le
périmètre des CERMES et leurs procédure
de mise en place notre commission a à
cœur de défendre une vision des CERMES
décentralisé penser par et pour les
territoires et adapt à leur spécificités
dans une logique d'équité territ
c'est pourquoi la commission a jugé
indispensable d'intégrer
systématiquement des lignes de car
express au projet de cerme ces lignes
permettront de relier les métropoles et
leurs périphéries les plus éloignées et
ce de manière plus souple et économe
qu'à travers le seul mode ferroviaire
les promesses de financement de l'État
étant ce qu'elles sont il nous revient
d'envisager des solutions multimodales
qui soient les plus efficientes poss
possiblebles pour nos territoires cela
est d'autant plus indispensable contenu
du calendrier très serré prévu par le
gouvernement s'agissant de la mise en
œuvre des zones à faible émission
mobilité ZFE et ce n'est pas notre faute
de ne pas avoir alerté à travers un
rapport d'information publié en juin
dernier sur le risque d'exclure de
l'accès aux métropole une part
importante de nos concitoyens en outre
les infrastructures ferroviaires
modernisées ou même construites dans le
cadre des Serbes ne seront pas
disponibles du jour au lendemain il faut
donc que chacun puisse bénéficier au
plus vite de moyens de transport
collectif adaptés c'est également la
raison pour laquelle la Commission
adopté un amendement précisant que la
décision de mettre en œuvre le contrôle
et les sanctions du respect des règles
applicables en ZFE tient compte le cas
échéant de l'avancement des CERMES cette
mise en cohérence est à mes yeux
essentielle l'urgence écologique rend
également impératif un déploiement
rapide descart express et ce même dans
un même objectif que la Commission
inclut dans les CERMES les réseaux
cyclables ainsi que le cas échéant le
covoiturage ou
l'éch pas l'écoartage l'autopartage
c'est un peu de l'échopartage également
j'en viens à mon 2e axe qui est un sujet
de préoccupation majeure de notre
commission il est essentiel que la
procédure de création des CERMES prenne
racine dans les territoires et notamment
dans les régions dans cette perspective
la Commission a confié au conseil
régional chef de fil des mobilités le
soin de proposer par une délibération la
création d'un cerme bien sûr cela ne
signifie pas qu'il faill écarter les
autres collectivités territoriales du
processus les CERMES ne peuvent
fonctionner que sur la base d'une
volonté territoriale et d'objectifs
définis et partagés entre tous les
acteurs locaux notamment les
départements et les
maires la Commission s'est également
penchée sur les enjeux de gouvernance en
veillant à son caractère collégial trans
transparent et tourné vers la qualité de
service et la sécurité des SERMES à ce
titre la Commission s'est aussi montrée
particulièrement vigilante aux
conditions d'intervention de la Société
du Grand Paris rebaptisé société des
grands projets nous avons souhaité
renforcer le rôle des collectivités dans
le choix de la SGP comme maître
d'ouvrage et ce n'est donc qu'à la
demande de la région et des autorités
organisatrice de la mobilité concernée
que cela pourra intervenir sous réserve
ensuite d' accord du ministre chargé des
transports puisqu'il est question du
réseau ferré national propriété de
l'État monsieur le ministre il n'en va
pas de même des lignes ferroviaires
transférées en gestion ou en propriété
aux collectivités territoriales pour
lesquelles la Commission a garanti la
possibilité de choisir ou nom de faire
intervenir l' SGP en tant que maître
d'ouvrage 3ème axe et dans le
prolongement de ces questions la
Commission s'est montré attentive à
garantir la bonne articulation des
interventions de la SGP d'une part et de
SNCF réseau et de sa filiale gare et
connexion d'autre part qui assure
respectivement la gestion du réseau feré
national et des gardes de voyageurs à ce
titre la Commission a confirmé le
principe de répartition des
responsabilités proposé par l'Assemblée
nationale la SGP pourra ainsi intervenir
en tant que maître d'ouvrage
essentiellement sur des infrastructures
nouvell du réseau ferré national mais
aussi sur des infrastructures non
utilisées depuis 5 ans ainsi que pour
des projets d'infrastructure de
transport public urbain ou périurbain en
correspondance avec l'une des gares
ferroviaire d'un cerme ainsi la SGP
pourra apporter au déploiement des
futurs CERMES toute l'expérience acquise
dans le cadre de la réalisation du Grand
Paris Express je rappelle et nos
collègues franciliens le savent très
bien qu'il s'agit ni plus ni moins du
plus grand projet d'infrastructure
d'Europe
elle pourra également faire bénéficier
les projets de de cerme de sa capacité
d'emprunt ce qui est un atout non
négligeable pour autant il n'est pas
évident évidemment question
d'archépéliser le réseau ferré national
qui relèvera toujours d' SNCF réseau la
Commission a donc été très attentive à
clarifier encore davantage le périmètre
et les modalités d'intervention de la
SGP dans le cadre des CERMES de même que
les conditions de remise des ouvrages
aux futurs gestionnaires
d'infrastructure quatrièmement j'en
viens donc à ce dernier axe qui est
relatif au modèle économique et
financiers des CERMES qui reste pour
l'heure la grand la grande inconnue
malgré vos propos rassurants monsieur le
ministre en effet ce texte ne règle en
rien la question du financement des
services express régionaux
métropolitains que ce soit en
investissement ou en fonctionnement or
alors que leur déploiement suppose des
dizaines de milliards d'investissements
tant en matière d'infrastructure que de
matériel roulant ferroviaire
l'engagement de l'État est à ce jour
très loin d'être à la hauteur une
enveloppe d'un montant de seulement 700
millions d'euros mais plutôt 800
millions d'euros si j'ai bien entendu
parce que c'est 700 que le Président de
la République avait annoncé alors même
qu'il y avait 800 millions d'euros que
vous aviez promis avant l'été mais vous
nous avez confirmé qu'on était plus sur
800 millions pour financer au mieux
certaines études préalables au-delà des
besoins d'investissement se posera
inévitablement la question du
financement de l'exploitation des CERMES
l'expérience du Grand Paris Express est
à cet ég éclairante et malheureusement
inquiétante je ne doute pas que nous
aurons l'occasion d'en discuter lors du
prochain examen du projet de loi de
finances pour 2024 de même que
s'agissant des effectifs de la SGP qui
voi le champ de ses missions élargi par
la présente proposition de loi sans que
ses moyens humains ne soit renforcé pour
autant avant même cette échéance la
Commission a adopté le principe de
l'organisation d'une conférence
nationale de financement des CERMES
d'ici le 30 juin 2024 cette réflexion
collective ne préjugera pas des
modalités de financement qui seront
retenues Infiné dans chaque territoire
en complément chers collègues et afin
d'éviter que le déploiement des CERMES
se traduise par de moindres
investissements dans la régénération et
la modernisation du réseau ferroviaire
la Commission a prévu d'annexer au
contrat de performance conclus par
l'État et SNCF réseau on reviendra pas
sur ce contrat on a dit beaucoup de
choses déjà dessus le programme annuel
des investissements de cette dernière en
faveur du réseau enfin avant de conclure
je vous indique que je vous soumettrai
tout à l'heure un amendement visant à
garantir la sécurité des usagers des
futur cerme à travers la conclusion
systématique d'un contrat d'objectif
départemental de sûreté dans les
transports je ne serai pas plus long je
vous remercie de votre
attention merci monsieur le rapporteur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Monsieur Yoshua
ochochard des nonincrits pour une duré
de 3
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues c'est en novembre dernier
qu'Emmanuel Macron annonce à la surprise
générale sa volonté de développer le
service ferroviaire dans 13 métropole
française pour un coût de 700 millions
d'euros sen est suivi tout un tas
d'annonces pour le secteur du
ferroviaire où en avril ellisabeth borne
premièreministre annonce un plan de 100
milliards d'euros dans le cadre d'un
plan de
développement puis la tournée des médias
du ministre délégué chargé des
transports qui évoque des pistes de
financement comme la taxation des
sociétés d'autoroute et donc
indirectement des usagers des autoroutes
privatisé ou encore la taxation du
secteur aérien en réalité ce plan de 100
milliards n'est pas ficelé personne ne
sait quand les CERMES seront
opérationnels ni qui les financera enfin
si il existe une grande probabilité que
ce soit les Français les plus modestes
qui soi encore mis à contribution pour
un gain d'efficacité quasi inexistant
dans les zones rurales la proposition de
loi place le ferroviaire comme élément
indispensable de la construction des
métropoles avant même la vision des
mobilités à long terme pour l'ensemble
des Français la mise en place encore une
fois de financement à hauteur de
plusieurs milliards d'euros dans les
zones urbaines sans le moindre bénéfice
pour les Français des zones
rurales chers collègues ce texte risque
d'aggraver les fractures qui existent au
niveau national entre les zones rurales
et les zon urbaine et périurbaine
l'article 1 est en ce sens assez clair
étant à réserver le stationnement dans
les gares épaau d'échange au vélo
véhicules de coiturage et autes moyens
de mobilité partagé cela signifie qu'un
habitant des zones rurales ou péis
urbaines seul mais prêt à consentir de
faire l'effort de laisser sa voiture
pour se rendre en ville en train est
exclu des gares etpôul d'échange pire il
ne pourra pas non plus se rendre en
ville avec sa voiture puisque vous
refusez de suspendre les zones à faible
émission
mobilité les plus riches seront libres
de se mouvoir et les plus pauvres quand
on est chez eux nous avons besoin de
garantie sur le fait que les zones
rurales seront désenclavées que les
habitants des zones rurales ne seront
pas encore une fois les grands oubliés
la France a besoin d'une loi de
programmation des transports et pas de
texte saucissonnés par-ci par là pêchant
toute vision à long terme de nombreux
projets doivent être étudié et la
qualité du réseau routier notamment des
routes secondaires doit aussi devenir
une priorité mais au fond monsieur le
ministre tout ce projet se refus de
favoriser la mobilité des Français
habitants en zone rurale ne sert souvent
que vos électeurs ceux qui se trouvent
essentiellement dans les grandes villes
et à proximité en punissant une certaine
façon ce qui selon vous votre
malin merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à Madame Lure
D'cos pour le
groupe Les Indépendants merci à vous
chers collègues vous avez 5
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues dans le
dans le cadre des objectifs que la
France s fixée en matière de transition
écologique les services express
régionaux métropolitains organisés par
la présente proposition de loi constitue
une innovation structurante pour nos
territoires je souhaite saluer le
travail consensuel effectué par notre
rapporteur philippe Tabarot la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire du développement durable et
le gouvernement il est vrai que pour
être acceptés par tous les projets liés
à la transition écologique mérite un
travail concerté et approfondi allant
dans le sens de l'intérêt des Français
surtout lorsque c la concerne les
mobilités s'agissant des investissements
liés à la réalisation des services
expresss régionaux métropolitains une
unanimité se dégage les besoins de
financement sont extrêmement importants
dans l'immédiat ils ne sont pas au
rendez-vous les 700 millions d'euros
annoncés par Emmanuel Macron sont
dérisoires au regard du coût du
déploiement des 10 CERMES d'ici 10 ans
estimé à minima autour de 15 milliards
d'euros infrastructure de transport et
matériel roulant compris au moment de
déterminer leur position sur ce texte
les sénateurs du groupe Les Indépendants
particulièrement insisteré sur ce point
notre groupe n'a de cesse de rappeler
que la transition écologique a un prix
c'est pourquoi nous saluons la création
de la Conférence nationale de
financement qui aura pour mission de
dégager des solutions pérennes en la
matière l'État ne pouvant pas tout à
l'évidence il nous faudra trouver des
financements publics certes mais aussi
aller chercher des solutions avec le
secteur privé si les moyens financiers
constituent le nerf de la guerre pour le
déploiement des CERMES il nous faudra
lever d'autres incertitudes
principalement techniques plusieurs
sénateurs ont soulevé des impossibilités
de nature opérationnell en effet dans de
nombreux territoires je pense à l'héro
ou à la Loire les sillons ferroviaires
sont déjà au maximum de leur capacité le
but n'est certainement pas de mettre en
place des CERMES en heure creuse nos
citoyens ont de réels besoins de
mobilité c'est pourquoi je me félicite
que la réflexion ne se limite pas au aux
étoiles ferroviaires et que l'Inter
modalité soit fortement encouragée cette
complémentarité est fondamentale mais là
encore je tiens à rappeler ce qui relève
de l'évidence ce qui qui est vrai pour
les sillons mais aussi pour le réseau
routier lorsqu'il s'agit d'écart à haut
niveau de service l'obligation
d'explorer la possibilité de voir
réservée inscrite à l'article 1er de la
proposition de loi est donc la bienvenue
nous avons des exemples d'expérience
réussies en Île-de-France il serait
judicieux de s'en inspirer par ailleurs
l'évolution de la Société du Grand Paris
en société des grands projets est un
apport majeur du texte que nous
examinons l'expérience capitalisée par
la SGP en matière de réalisation de
projets structurants en l'occurrence les
lignes 15 et 18 du Grand Paris Express
est essentiel pour la réussite des CMEs
leur gouvernance à l'cout des acteurs du
terrain a été exemplaire depuis
plusieurs années je me réjouis donc de
voir jeter les bases d'une coopération
entre SNCF réseau et la SGP nous serons
attentifs à ce que cela produise des
bénéfices avérés pour les usagers et les
territoires je tiens à ce sujet à mettre
l'accent sur la place des collectivités
territorial région et département
surtout qui a été dégagé par la
proposition de loi la France doit
poursuivre sa marche
décentralisatrice laisser les
collectivités à la manœuvre sur ces
questions de transport collectif marque
sans aucun doute une première étape du
renouveau démocratique que représente la
décentralisation des décisions nous
pouvons nous en féliciter faisons
confiance à nos territoires qui
connaissent parfaitement leurs besoins
et particulièrement à nos maères les
consulter en amont du déploiement d'un
projet de service express régional
métropolitain sur leur territoire relève
de l'évidence le rôle des maires au plus
près de nos concitoyens et des usagers
permet de faire émerger des solutions
équilibrées et réalistes mettre les
acteurs concernés autour de la table
au-delà du respect dû au territoire à
leur spécificités c'est assurer une
réponse en harmonie avec les nécessités
des bassins de vie que serviront les RER
métropolitains même si le chemin reste
long les projets de cerme semblent avec
cette proposition de loi pouvant être
lancés sous les meilleurs auspices le
groupe Les Indépendants restera
toutefois vigilant sur les questions
relatives aux moyens financiers et
techniques pour lesquels les solutions
pérennes n'ont pas encore été trouvées
il votera en faveur de ce texte afin
d'accélérer et consolider ce processus
supplémentaire de transition juste pour
nos territoires je vous
remerci merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Franck dersin
pour le groupe Union centriste pour une
durée de 8
minutes
merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues j'ai l'honneur
de m'adresser à vous depuis cette
tribune pour la première fois je suis
particulièrement heureux que cette
première intervention en tant qu'orateur
de mon groupe Union centriste puisse
porter sur les rur métropolitain dont je
connais à la fois l'impérieuse nécessité
mais aussi l'immense complexité dans
leur mise en œuvre étant pour quelques
jours encore vice-président de la Région
haute-fance en charge des
mobilités venant d'un territoire
travaillant d'ors et déjà avec la SGP
sur le futur projet donc du sererme
Lillois je mesure pleinement
l'importance de la proposition de loi
que nous avons aujourd'hui à étudier en
tant qu'élu régional je me réjouis
d'avance de pouvoir compter sur la
société des grands projets puisque c'est
ainsi qu'elle va s'appeler pour mener à
bien dans nos métropoles ce grand dessin
que constitue la création de service
express
métropolitain la présence de moyens de
transport modne câble et décarboné ne
peut demeurer le seul appanage de la
région capitale le temps est venu
d'équiper nos grandes métropoles de
réseaux de transport à la hauteur de
leur poids économique et social alors
que la livraison des premiers ouvrages
construits par la SGP pointe son nez
avec le prolongement au nord et au sud
de la ligne 14 du métro parisien faisant
d'elle un standard mondial d'efficacité
et de modernité je crois qu'il faut
saluer mais surtout se rendre compte du
travail effectué par la Société du Grand
Paris depuis sa création en 2010 en
seulement 13 années cette structure
passée de quelques dizaines à 1000
collaborateurs environ est en train de
mener à bien le plus grand chantier
d'Europe cela a été dit par l'ensemble
des orateurs il s'agit ni plus ni moins
de doubler en moins de 20 ans la taille
du réseau de métro parisien existant ce
qui est absolument colossal le Grand
Paris Express a nécessité la création de
cette société ad hoc qui n'avait jusqu'à
maintenant vocation à perdurer dans le
temps euh c'est dernières années il est
apparu qu'il serait malheureux pour ne
pas dire regrettable de se passer de
cette expertise accumulée au cours des
années dans cet esprit ce texte fruit
d'un travail de concertation entre SNCF
réseau et la GP porte des mesures de
coordination de simplification qui
permetttront de décliner au local des
solutions de transport ambitieuses en
respectant les souhaits des
collectivités au sein de structures
juridiques dirigé par elle pour que les
CERMES soient un succès il faudra que la
société des grands projets les
collectivités ainsi que SNCF réseau et
garé connexion mettent en place dans
chacun de ces projets locaux un dialogue
franc sincère apaisé le compromis trouvé
à l'occasion de ce texte me laisse
penser que chacun de ces acteurs est
prêt à travailler afin de parvenir au
meilleurs résultats en terme
d'efficacité et surtout de rapidité je
souhaiterais néanmoins appeler votre
attention chers collègues sur deux
points particuliers dont je l'avoue j'ai
du mal à saisir la pertinence dans nos
régions respectives nous connaissons des
exemples où la mise en place d'un
sererme nécessitera des travaux
importants sur de l'infrastructure
exploitée que ce soit une voie circulée
ou une garee de voyageur prenons
l'exemple de la gare de Marseille
Saint-Charles il est évident que la mise
en place du cerme d'ex-marseille
nécessitera une refonte intégrale de la
gare Saint-Charles avec une mise en
souterrain d'une partie importante des
circulations telle que la proposition de
loi est écrite aujourd'hui les GP ne
pourrait pas intervenir sur un tel
chantier car cette gare est en
exploitation je souhaite souligner donc
le caractère un peu illogique de cette
rédaction et pour tirer bénéfice à plein
de l'expertise accumulée de la GP il
faut permettre au ministre à vous
monsieur le ministre des Transports et
aussi aux collectivités concernées de
décider au cas par cas euh des solutions
de maîrice d'ouvrage les plus
appropriées euh par ailleurs personne
n'imagine un seul instant que dans le
casadre d'un tel chantier la IGP ne soit
pas accompagné sur le terrain de son
partenaire SNCF raison de manière tout à
fait analogue la proposition de loi ne
permet pas non plus à les GP
d'intervenir sur des projets
d'infrastructure de transport hors cerme
imaginons qu'une métropole souhaite
construire une nouvelle ligne de métro
sans correspondance avec une gare du
cerme elle ne pourra pas faire appel à
l'gp si le texte était adopté comme
telle je crois que cette loi doit être
facilitatrice et non restrictive il me
semble qu'il serait bon à loi de laisser
aux pouvoirs réglementaires ainsi qu'aux
collectivités les possibilités de
décider pour eux-mêmes au local des
solutions les plus adaptées à leur
territoire même si le financement des
CERMES n'est pas l'objet de cette PPL je
crois que nous avons un devoir de
vigilance sur ce point ça a été aussi
rappelé par les orateurs il ne faut pas
promettre des miracles sans pouvoir les
financer alors que le Président de la
République a annoncé avoir décidé de
flécher environ je rectifie 800 millions
et non plus 700 millions d'euros dans
les contrats de plan état région afin de
réaliser des études techniques sur les
premiers SERMES ce qui est nettement
insuffisant enfin vous avez qualifié
vous-même tout à l'heure dans votre
discours de Somme à caractère indicative
donc je suppose que ça ne peut être que
plus dans l'avenir donc la question du
financement des investissements lourds
reste absolument
entière je crois que là encore le modèle
du Grand Paris Express doit constituer
un exemple à reproduire le financement
de l'investissement doit être pensé dès
le début de la phase de conception afin
de permettre à l'ensemble des acteurs
d'avoir une vision claire des tenants et
aboutissants du projet quand il est
question d'infrastructure à plusieurs
milliards d'euros et de plans de
financement pluannuel enjambant dans de
nombreux cas les échéances politiques
locales ces derniers doivent être
limpide et anticipé il nous faudra faire
preuve de créativité dans les ressources
financières à mobiliser le modèle de
fiscalité affecté propre Grand Paris
Express ne pourra pas être reproduit à
l'identique dans nos différentes régions
à l'évidence l'assiette fiscale y est
plus faible et ne permettra pas de lever
des sommes sur les marchés à des taux
aussi compétitifs je doute et et je ne
suis absolument pas favorable vous le
savez à une fiscalité locale
supplémentaire et à des impôts locaux
supplémentaires pour nos territoires
j'appelle donc solinement l'état à
prendre sa part dans le financement de
ces infrastructures à minima il faudra
qu'un débat s'engage dans les prochains
mois sur les modalités de financement de
ces CERMES qui demeurent pour l'instant
tout à fait je dirais obscur je salue à
cet égard l'amendement mon rapporteur de
la Commission visant à sécuriter à
sécuriser la tenue d'une conférence de
financement des CERMES ce sera un moment
très important un rendez-vous très
important de manière analogue à plus
long terme il nous faudra également
lancer une refonte du financement de
l'exploitation de ces
infrastructures ce qui nécessitera une
discussion franche sur la manière de
donner aux collectivités les moyens
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement de
transport publics il nous faut à tout
prix éviter les fiascos que nous avons
connus récemment afin d'Er d'aider nos
collectivités à s'engager dans ce
magnifique projet national que peut
constituer la création de ces CERMES aux
quatre coins de l'hexagone mon groupe
votera donc sans aucune une réserve en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Jacques
ferernque pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire pour une durée
de 5
minutes merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues avec les
CERMES ce qui est visé c'est un choc
massif d'offre de service des transports
du quotidien pour au moins au moins une
grosse dizaine de nos métropoles notre
pays accuse un net retard nombre de nos
projet n'avance pas juste ceux du lément
express de Strasbourg et de Bordeaux ont
d'ors et déjà atteint des niveaux
significatif l'ambition c'est tout
simplement d'en finir avec cette lourde
réalité qui fait que 90 % des
déplacements entre 10 et 80 km se font
en voiture et la plupart du temps seul
dans sa voiture
en grande périphérie périphérie des
villes la part modale des transports
collectifs chute brutalement par rapport
aux agglomération centre on passe de 27
% dans les pôles à 5 % dans les
couronnes c'est donc là que réside le
potentiel le plus important de
décarbonation compte tenu des longues
distances quotidiennes parcourues en
véhicules individuels c'est toute
l'ambition des CERMES celle de la
cohésion territoriale de la République
face aux inégalités d'offres de
transport décarboné durable ces
inégalités que pointaient justement les
gilets jaunes alors ce n'est pas ce
texte une PPL qui peut déterminer une
trajectoire financière mais cette phase
d'examen parlementaire doit faire monter
la pression là-dessus personne ne peut
nier la nécessité de construire des
trajectoire financière pour assurer les
coûts d'exploitation des fortes
augmentations de services et des
investissements nouveaux parfois
nécessaires en ce sens nous saluons
l'apport du rapporteur proposant des
tarifs de pH ferroviaire plus
supportables dans les périmètres des
CERMES l'apport aussi d'une conférence
nationale de financement des CERMES les
amendements socialistes pour la
construction de trajectoires de
financement le texte identifie les
éléments d'une labellisation le
rapporteur a eu raison de rehausser
l'importance des cararts express de la
même façon l'intégration à part entière
des réseaux cyclables sera un formidable
accélérateur d'intermodalité et de
décarbonation le texte propose des
dispositions pour faciliter une
gouvernance pas évidente entre région
l'Inter commmunalité AOM centre les
autres interc périphériques impactés
département aussi cette bonne
gouvernance permettra sans doute de bien
prendre en compte les besoins et les
attentes des usagers qui ont besoin de
mobilité quotidienne fluide et pratique
et qui se contrefiche passez-moi
l'expression des précarrés de nos
différentes collectivités nous ne
pouvons donc pas au Sénat supprimer
abruptement de ce texte la nécessité
d'aller vers une billeéthique intégrée
bien sûr le mieux est souvent l'ennemi
du bien l'amendement de rétablissement
que nous proposons a le souci de la
nuance pragmatique qui pourrait être un
compromis positif ne réduisons pas le
rôle de l'autorité organisatrice des
mobilités porteuse d'un projet sererme
et l'importance de la dynamique qu'elle
pilotera elle n'a pas besoin que la loi
lui impose de consulter chacun des maire
elle le fera naturellement sa
délibération est importante comme celle
de la région pour dem à l'état la
reconnaissance du statut de cerme au
projet mon groupe propose des
amendements là-dessus la nouveauté
déterminante c'est la vocation nouvelle
que ce texte encadre pour la Société du
Grand Paris partant du constat des
acquis de cet établissement public il
serait dommage en effet de démtheler
tout cela après le Grand Paris Express
réalisé la société des grands projets
c'est la possibilité de conditions
d'emprunt favorable pas de carcan
d'annualité budgétaire la faculté de
taxe affecté local et bien sur
l'expérience et l'expertise de ces
équipes il était essentiel de garantir
l'unicité de la gestion du réseau
ferroviaire notre rapporteur a amendé
pour préciser que c'est à titre gratuit
que réseau etgar et connexion
récupéreront les infranouvelles il
serait incompréhensible monsieur le
ministre que le gouvernement et
l'Assemblée nationale veuillent
supprimer cette précision essentielle
deux dispositions ajoutées en commission
sont à notre sens contreproductives et
il faudrait y revenir aujourd'hui
vouloir conditionner mécaniquement les
contrôles et sanctions des ZFE à
l'existence d'un cerme avancé à
l'apparence d'une bonne idée ce serait
inévitablement utilisé comme un prétexte
à l'immobiliste dans la lutte contre la
pollution de l'air d'origine automobile
ce serait aussi je le crois bien une
petite entorse à l'article 45 et au
périmètre de cette PPL il serait de même
singulier de détourner l'esprit du zan
zéro artificialisation net en imputant
la consommation foncière occasionnée par
les CERMES au forfait national alors que
ce sont des projets d'intérêt régional
dans le cadre du forfait régional on
sera sans doute plus attentif à la
consommation d'espace pour conclure
cette proposition de loi est positive
ces dispositions seront utiles pour
faciliter la mise en œuvre des services
express régionaux métropolitains leur
donner de la cohérence les amplifier
pour provoquer aussi une clarification
et une sécurisation des financements
nécessaires mon groupe la
votera merci beaucoup chers collègues la
parole est maintenant à Monsieur Pierre
Baros du groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste kanaki pour une
durée de 5
minutes madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues nous passons beaucoup de temps
dans les transports notamment en voiture
à elle seul représente 72 % des trajets
domicile travail
la voiture est pourtant responsable de
94 % des émissions de CO2 du secteur des
transports et 40000 personnes décèdent
chaque année à cause de la pollution de
l'air un impact écrasant sur le climat
et la
santé on est attaché à la bagnole on
aime la bagnole et moi je l'adore
déclarait récemment le président de la
République c'est sans doute ce qui
explique son peu d'ambition pour le
ferroviaire et pour les alternatives à
la voiture au camion htier des
politiques d'aménagement du TER qui
servissent depuis les années 60 et
favorisent le tout automobile les
Français aimeraient pourtant pouvoir se
déplacer facilement sans que cela leur
coûte trop cher s'ils prennent
malheureusement leur voiture c'est
souvent parce qu'ils n'ont pas d'autre
choix la mobilité est un droit qu'il
nous faut réaffirmer en octroyant de
réels moyens au transport collectifs et
aux services publics il faut les rendre
davantage accessible et efficace pour
développer la qualité de vie et lutter
contre le dérèglement
climatique nous discutons aujourd'hui
d'un texte qui est passé par le filtre
de l'Assemblée nationale puis par celui
de la commission aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
j'aimerais saluer les travaux qui ont
été réalisés collectivement par la
Commission et qui amélior nettement la
version initiale à travers cette
nouvelle proposition de loi j'entrevois
une volonté claire de matérialiser un
véritable maillage de transport dans les
grandes agglomérations du pays
l'intermodalité s'inscrit au cœur des
services express régionaux
métropolitains grâce au projet de
déploiement de RER métropolitain
j'espère sincèrement qu'ils aboutiront
tout cela reste tout de même du domaine
de l'hypothèse car si nous saluons les
intentions il reste à déterminer les
moyens notamment financiers qui sont mis
sur la table j'ai bien noté monsieur le
ministre les moyens conséquents qui sont
mis et qui ont fait évoluer la les
enveloppes mais ça reste à confirmer
malgré tout le président de la
République annoncéit fièrement fin
septembre qu'il y aurait 700 maintenant
800 millions d'euros dédiés aux erreur
métropolitain j'ai bien compris aussi
que que c'était pour commencer les
études mais c'est un chiffre très
important certes mais tous les travaux
du Sénat annoncent plutôt un effort
minimal entre 15 et 20 milliards d'euros
pour développer les lignes imaginées par
le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures ces 800 millions
paraissent donc bien d'arisoir et nous
serons très attentifs lors du projet de
loi de financeces 2024 à défendre les
moyens nécessaires au développement des
transports ferroviaires car si nous
voulons garantir une égalité d'accès à
ces services cela ne peut reposer
uniquement et une fois de plus encore
que sur les collectivités territoriales
cela ne peut non plus reposer sur des
conditions de travail peu attractifes
pour les agents ni sur une tarification
en décalage avec les moyens des usagers
qui auront besoin de ces services à
contrario les moyens structurels nous
pensons en effet les avoir ce texte
propose de nous appuyer sur les
compétences de l'expérience de la
Société des grands Paris bientôt société
des grands projets et sur celle aussi de
SNCF réseau c'est une très grande et
bonne idée mais il faudra aussi
apprendre les des erreurs notamment cell
de Grand Paris Express qui n'a pas su
tenir les coûts le calendrier et qui
aura contribué à artificialiser ou
rendre inexploitable nombre d'espac
agricooles en Île-de-France mon groupe
proposa tout de même de limiter le
recours à des prestataires externes tant
nous devons profiter des atouts et
compétences des acteurs publics plus à
même de porter l'intérêt général qui
nous tient à cœur ainsi vous l'aurez
compris nous trouvons ce texte porte des
intentions claires pour décarboner les
mobilités mais que des améliorations
sont possibles
nous vous les soumettrons en séance pour
pouvoir aboutir à un texte auquel nous
serions davantage favorable dononsn des
objectifs de report modal réellement
efficace garantissons des financements
de la part de l'État soyons exigeant sur
la qualité des aménagements des pôles
d'échang multimodaux sur la qualité des
services proposons et défondons un prix
du billet supportable pour les usagers
c'est le sens à donner à ces nouveaux
services express régionaux
métropolitains dans le cas contraire les
bases que nous posons avec ce texte de
nêtre affichage de plus offrant
simplement un label qui ne répondra ni
au besoins des usagers ni à nos
territoires ni à l'urgence
climatique merci beaucoup chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Madame Véronique Guillotin du groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen pour 5
minutes monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de commission monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues je suis
pas une grande habituée des des
discussions générales de mobilité mais
étant donné que la raison Grand Est est
fort impactée par ce par ce texte c'est
avec un grand plaisir que je me présente
aujourd'hui voilà 4 ans 4 ans qui ont
été nécessaires depuis les priorités
dessinées dans la loi d'orientation des
mobilités de 2019 pour enfin développer
un cadre légal permettant d'accélérer le
développement des mobilités du quotidien
tout en désenclavant nos territoires et
en offrant à nos con citoyens de
nouvelles offres de mobilité adapté et
décarboné le groupe RDSE qui partage le
souci de l'équilibre entre les
territoires souscrit naturellement aux
objectifs et ambitions de cette
proposition de loi les enjeux de
développement de nos territoires sont
plus que jamais cruciaux pour
l'équilibre de notre pays où la fracture
sociale et économique s'intensifie face
à la métropolisation de notre
développement économique tiré par une
tendance à la concentration géographique
des emplois cadres il faut effectivement
la capacité à nos pipérie de faire
réseau avec leur pôle d'attraction
devant ces défis multiples et
transversaux nos réponses doivent
impliquer tous les acteurs concernés en
ce sens nous félicitons les travaux qui
ont été menés par le Sénat lors de
l'examen du texte en commission et
notamment par son rapporteur philippe
Tabarot les services express régionaux
métropolitains doivent être pensés par
et pour les territoires et c'est bien
l'esprit de la commission les
collectivités territoriales dés
désormais placé au cœur du processus de
décision se sont enfin vu attribuer les
outils de coordination nécessaires
cependant au-delà d'être collective
notre réflexion devra d'emblé être
multimodale plus que de simples RER
métropolitain les services express
régionaux métropolitains seront de
véritable chocs d'offre pour les
transports collectifs les cernes doivent
pouvoir tirer le maximum de la
complémentarité entre les transports
collectifs routiers et ferroviaires afin
de répondre au mieux à l'urgence
climatique aux inégalités et
particularités territoriales ainsi
qu'aux aspirations des Français en
matière de mobilité dans leur bassin de
vie une offre de car à haut niveau de
service le développement de réseau
cyclabl et la promotion du covoiturage
et de l'autopartage devront
systématiquement accompagner le
déploiement des
CERMES facile à mettre en place et peu
coûteux ils permettront de répondre à
l'urgence impérative de décarbonation
des mobilités et d'accompagner la mise
en place des ZFE en évitant d'exclure
certains usagers du cœur des villes une
préoccupation don ma collègue Nathalie
del c'est attaché à travers l'adoption
en commission de son amendement visant à
ce que la mise en œuvre de dispositifs
de contrôle et de sanction du respect
des règles en ZF tiennent compte du
déploiement des CERMES notre groupe est
profondément convaincu que ZFE et CERM
sont complémentaires qu'il ne faut pas
les opposer afin d'atteindre nos
obligations écologiques et améliorer la
qualité de l'air et de vie des Français
à condition de répondre aux exigences
d'acceptabilité et de justice sociale or
nous ne pouvons pas pénaliser nos
concitoyens qui recour à la voiture
individuelle s'ils n'ont pas encore
d'alternative crédiible et efficace
néanmoins si partager les objectifs de
ce texte c'est une chose nous ne pouvons
faire l'impasse comme les groupes l'ont
fait précédemment sur les financements
je ne vous apprends rien si je vous dis
que l'argent est le ner de la guerre et
que dire choc d'offre de service
quelquefois veut également dire mur de
financement cette proposition de loi ne
fixe en effet pas les garanties de
financement et ce n'est pas son objet ce
qui constitue quand même un un motif
d'inquiétude à ce jour l'état annonce un
déblocage et vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre de 800 millions d'euros en
faveur des CERMES mais on sait que la
note se contrraint en plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'euros avec différents
projets de différentes natures et
hauteur de financement Le plan de
nouvelle donne ferroviaire de l'ordre de
100 milliards d'euros d'ici 2040 ne
précise pas encore le montant attribué
au développement des seres nous serons
donc extrêmement attentif et vigilant
aux réponses qu'apportera la Conférence
nationale de financement des services
express régionaux métropol poain
organisé d'ici le 30 juin par ailleurs
passer l'investissement dans l' dans
l'infrastructure c'est toute une qualité
d'exploitation qu'il faudra assurer du
matériel roulant au gare en passant par
le personnel et la programmation des
sillons et des expériences notamment à
Strasbourg doivent attirer notre
attention enfin notre groupe déposera un
amendement en séance afin d'éclaircir le
périmètre d'établissement des CERMES
aucun territoire aucune commune soumise
à l'air d'attraction ne doit être oublié
que ce soit dans le processus de
concertation initiale ou dans dans le
déploiement effectif du cerme il nous
semble en effet nécessaire d'établir un
périmètre précis objectif permettant
d'éviter une aspiration des financement
Paris pour les métropoles auquel cas la
cible principale du texte serait manqué
à savoir le désenclavement des
territoires ruraux et périurbain l'enjeu
de ce texte dépasse celui de la mobilité
il s'agit effectivement de construire
ensemble l'aménagement durable des
territoires ou liberté d'action
flexibilité souplesse opérationnelle
devront être ces nouveaux dogmes ement
le groupe RDSE votera favorablement
cette proposition de loi merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Madame Nadj av du groupe rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant pour une durée de 7
minutes merci madame la Présidente et je
profite de cette prise de parole pour
vous féliciter de votre élection à ce
poste monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur le
ministre ministre mes chers collègues
cette proposition de loi dont nous
partageons l'esprit sur tous nos bancs
vient organiser juridiquement le
déploiement des services express
régionaux métropolitains dans plusieurs
grandes villes en France il s'agit dans
les fait d'accroître sensiblement la
part du transport ferroviaire dans les
déplacements du quotidien avec un
service public à la fois plus dense plus
performant qui s'appuie sur l'ature
existante et la réouverture de lignes
oubliées il nous faut pour se faire non
seulement augmenter la fréquence de
passage et les amplitudes horaires mais
aussi bien entendu mieux irriguer les
alentours des grandes villes concernées
afin de désenclaver les territoires
insuffisamment connectés périurbains et
ruraux sur le modèle des RER francilien
mais avec l'impératif de déclinaison
propre à chaque réalité territoriale et
j'y reviendrai il est aussi question
évidemment de répondre à l'urgence
environnementale avec une accélération
de la planification écologique rendue
possible par de nouvelles offres de
mobil adapté et décarboné la première
ministre le souignait en février c'est
lorsque nos concitoyensens pourront
trouver un transport en commun régulier
facilement accessible et fiable qu'ils
pourront réduire leur usage à la voiture
le groupe RDPI soutient pleinement
l'ambition et le dispositif porté par ce
texte déposé par le député Jean-Marc
zulési et je tiens ici à rendre hommage
à son action adopté en première lecture
à l'Assemblée nationale avant l'été
notre commission l'a approuvé mercredi
dernier et je salue notre rapporteur
Philippe tabarau pour son travail cette
avancée législative s'inscrit en
continuité d'engagement déjà pris
notamment dans le cadre de la loi des
d'orientation des mobilités faisant
suite à cette promulgation et au rapport
du Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructure en 2018 SNCF réseau avait
alors élaboré un schéma directeur dans
le but de désaturer les étoiles
ferroviaire et de développer ses
services express cette nécessité d'une
meilleure desserte à a été défendu par
le Président de la République en
novembre dernier il l'a réaffirmé en
septembre à l'issue du conseil de
planification écologique une priorité
nationale qui trouve ici une déclinaison
attendue dans le dispositif des CERMES
qui d qui entendent transformer la
mobilité pour des millions d'usagers
l'Inter et la multimodalité tiennent une
place fondamentale s'il est évidemment
question d'infrastructure l'ambition
s'inscrit dans un aménagement bien plus
global de notre territoire d'une
réflexion approfondie dès la conception
non seulement sur l'intégration des
services existants mais aussi sur une
offre élargie pas d'opposition mais une
complémentarité entre les déplacements
en commission les réseaux cyclables et
les lignes transport routiers à haut
niveau de service ont été incluses dans
la définition des CERMES de même que le
cas échéant le covoiturage et
l'autopartage en plus du transport
fluvial la création et l'adaptation de
gare ou pôle d'échange multimod dal
notre groupe partage par ailleurs cette
volonté que les élus notamment les
maires soient pleinement associés au
processus de consultation afin de
garantir une prise en compte adéquate
des intérêts locaux j'y faisais
référence il existera autant de CERMES
que de territoire retenu en outre afin
de confirmer le rôle de chef de fil des
mobilités de l'échelon régional la
Commission a prévu qu'une délibération
du conseil régional concerné soit prise
pour décider de créer une cerme nous y
sommes là encore FA
nous soutenons également le principe
d'un renforcement de la collégialité
entre les maîtres d'ouvrage et de
l'implication des financeurs autre
objectif faire intervenir un maître
d'ouvrage dans ce déploiement la SGP
dont l'expertise reconnue ne doit pas
être perdu mais partagé il s'agit de
décliner un modèle à la française
reconnu à l'internationale disposant
d'une importante capacité d'emprunt et
d'un fonctionnement souple mais il ne
s'agit ni de centraliser la gouvernance
des CERMES ni d'en faire un concurrent
avec la SNCF la SGP devra permettre la
création de sociétés de projets local
pour chaque territoire qui déterminera
alors la gouvernance adaptée et nous
défendons à ce propos que la décision
d'intervention de la SGP sur les projets
proviennent bien d'une demande des
collectivités porteuses la région et les
AOM ce chantier s'appuiera ensuite sur
une expertise partagée entre SNCF réseau
et laasgp avec une répartition des rôles
clairs et des discussions avec les
exécutifs locaux concernés la compétence
de la SGP n'inclura ainsi pas les
infrastructures et les installation de
services déjà en exploitation afin de
tenir compte de son évolution le groupe
RDPI a souhaité déposer deux amendements
et nous en discuteront à l'article 2
construire les futurs CERMES avec
l'ambition exposée précédemment c'est
enfin nécessairement entreprendre des
investissement significatifs en février
dernier la première ministre a également
pu annoncer un plan de 100 milliards
d'euros pour pour le ferroviaire d'ici à
2040 vous avez lancé monsieur le
ministre avant l'été les négociations du
volet mobilité des contrats de plan ét
région portant sur la période
2023-2027 l'État s'est alors engagé à
mobiliser 8,6 milliards d'euros sur la
période plus de 750 millions d'euros
seront fléchés sur les cernes la
déclinaison du plan de financement qui
devra accompagner les demandes de
labelllisation est vous le savez très
attendu au-delà de la forme du cadre que
cela prendra nous partageons la
nécessité de solutions partagées à
mettre en œuvre pour assurer un
financement pérenne des dépenses
d'investissement et de fonctionnement
monsieur le ministre je tiens en
conclusion à rendre hommage à votre
volontarisme en matière de relance et de
déploiement du du ferroviaire en France
et vous avez apporté jeudi des
précisions quant à la mise en œuvre du
passeril qui doit permettre plus
d'attractivité afin de rendre possible
un choc d'offre accessible qui fait
appel à l'intelligence collective
territoriale nous voterons ce texte et
essentiel qui concrétise une ambition
nationale en même temps qu'il répond à
un impératif écologique je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant à Olivier Jacquin du groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour une durée de 6
minutes euh madame la présidente et je
suis ravi de reprendre du service sous
cette présidence éclairée monsieur le
ministre chers collègues il y a un peu
moins d'un an alors que nous étions en
pleine préparation budgétaire nous
apprim au détour d'une vidéo que le
Président de la République décida sur un
coup de tête de déployer 10 projets de
RER métropolitain un nouveau fait du
prince un nouvel épisode de
l'incohérence complète de la politique
qu'il mène en matière de transport
depuis 2017 passant un jour des
mobilités du quotidien à la relance de
la grande vitesse le lendemain suivi
d'un contrat de performance de SNCF
résseau qui bloque le ferroviaire et
nous voilà revenu à la case départ sans
que les étapes précédentes ne soient
requestionné et nous en serons empêchés
aujourd'hui puisque l'article 40 a
frappé mon amendement pour réformer ce
contrat de performance et mettre fin au
carcan de SNCF réseau alors que le
ministre a entamé cet été des
concertations pour bâtir une nécessaire
nouvelle loi de programmation des
infrastructures et que l'ensemble des
acteurs à commencé par les collectivités
crie au manque de financement nous
sommes amenés à débattre de la création
d'une nouvelle offre de mobilité et si
je salue le retour de la priorité aux
mobilité du quotidien à travers ce texte
je pense monsieur le ministre et sans
faire offense au présidents zouisi qu'un
projet de loi aurait été plus adapté en
plus d'une étude d'impact et d'un avis
du Conseil d'État vous auriez pu plus
aisément y acc un indispensable volet
financement et éviter qu'une nouvelle
fois nous ne légiférions à l'aveugle
puisque'à l'URE du 493 nous n'avons
aucune idée de ce qu'il adviendra de nos
avancées lors des débats budgétaires
mais Simon hna mon collègue reviendra
sur la question des financements après
moi je suis chers collègues
particulièrement heureux de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle
pour parler de mobilité du quotidien dès
le début de cette session permettez-moi
dès à présent de u et remercier le
rapporteur philippe Tabarot pour son
excellent travail il a adopté un esprit
tant d'ouverture que de compromis tout
au long de ces dernières semaines afin
que nous aboutissions à un texte le plus
consensuel possible si la moitié d'entre
nous étaient en campagne ces derniers
mois toutes et tous nous avons été
interpellés sur ce sujet prgant des
mobilités le déploiement des solutions
contenues dans la boîte à outils qui a
été la loi d'orientation des mobilités
de 2019 est en cours et encore inachevé
nous nous accueillons donc très
positivement cette nouvelle brique dans
la boîte à outils elle servira à
stimuler les autres en développant de
nouveaux services dans une dizaine de
métropoes du moins en l'état actuel du
texte et c'est là-dessus que je voudrais
m'arrêter chers collègues déjà
parlementaires ou non aucun d'entre nous
n'a oublié la crise des gilets jaunes et
les fractures sociales et territorial
qu'elle a révélé le danger est grand
qu'elle ne ressurgisse à l'ône du
développement de ces a dans les seules
métropoles si nous ne prenons pas
correctement en compte leur périphérie
et même leur air d'attractivité c'est
d'autant plus vrai alors des zones à
faible émission déjà mal accepté et des
mesures compensatoires trop faible et
trop lente à déployer le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
salue donc le fait que l'assemblée ait
décidé cet été d'étendre l'intention
d'Emmanuel Macron en passant de simples
projets de réseau express métropolit à
de véritables services express régionaux
métropolitains sortant de fait du seul
mode
ferroviaire la moitié du chemin est
faite allons au bout de la logique si
nous voulons être à la hauteur de nos
ambitions climatiques nous ne pouvons
nous contenter de 10 projets dans les
plus grandes métropoles osons le choc
d'offre comme nous y invite SNCF réseau
depuis 2020 la fnot nos grandes
entreprises de transport de nombreux
présidents de région et d'agglomération
ou encore le conseil orientation des
infrastructures quittons la seule
logique métropolitaine pour celle des
mobilités pour tous étendons cette belle
idée des CERMES à des agglomérations de
plus petite taille elle ne saurait être
réservé au seul métropole organisant les
déplacements de demain autour d'une
offre complète de service en s'appuyant
sur les logiques de rabattement depuis
la voiture individuel socialisé par le
covoiturage l'autopartage et le vélo
vers les transports plus lourd le bus à
au niveau de service et les trains
accompagnons les collectivités purbaines
pour offrir des solutions aux habitants
qui seront demain exclus des afeu pour
qu'ils puissent continuer de venir
travailler étudier et accéder au
services publics qui ont souvent disparu
de leur environnement immédiat à
commencer par les professionnels de
santé bien sûr et nous y reviendrons
longuement le ferroviaire doit avoir une
place prépondérante dans cette
organisation et rester qu qu'il existe
l'épine dorsale de l'écosystème de
mobilité nous aurons les débats
concernant la transformation de la
Société du Grand Paris et les garanties
à apporter à sensef réseau comme à gare
et connexion ainsi qu'à leurs salariés
nous aurons les débats techniques
concernant les pactes de gouvernance
avec les collectivités la planification
et la labilisation l'interopérabilité ou
encore les contrats opérationnel de
mobilité mais je veux profiter de cette
discussion générale pour vous enjoindre
à travers cette proposition de loi
bienvenue mais encore incomplète à poser
les bases d'un grande politique publique
de mobilité qui n'oublie aucun
territoire et encore moins la nécessaire
transformation de nos déplacements face
à l'urgence climatique faisons confiance
à nos régions et intercommunalité don
donnonsleur tous les outils et tous les
moyens pour développer des services
complets ambitieux et adapté aux
réalités locales c'était l'ambition de
la Lom avec la création des bassins de
mobilité et les transferts de
compétences aux AOM il est plus que
temps de concrétiser ce travail auquel
le Sénat avait massivement contribuer
alors allons-y je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est maintenant
à Monsieur Didier Mandelli du groupe les
républicains pour 7
[Applaudissements]
minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur chers
Philippe mes chers collègues je me
réjouis que la présente proposition de
loi traduise enfin les ambitions
affichées dans la loi d'orientation sur
lesmobilité promulgué fin 2019 désaturer
les villes et leurs accès améliorer les
liaisons entre les territoires ruraux
péurbains et les pôles urbains tes étai
les priorités la loi d'orientation des
mobilités porté par la ministre
d'orlisabeth borne je vous souhaite
trajectoire monsieur le ministre et dont
j'étais rapporteur pour le Sénat pour
mémoire la programmation financière et
opérationnelle des investissements de
l'État fixé par cette loi visit
notamment à réduire les inégalités
territoriales renforcer l'accessibilité
des villes moyennes et des territoires
mal connectés au métropole ainsi que les
offres de déplacement du
quotidien l'un des cinq programmes
d'investissement porté sur la résorption
de la saturation des grands œufs
ferroviaires avec pour objectif le
doublement de la part modale du
transport ferroviaire dans les grands
pôles urbains malheureusement ainsi que
nous l'avons exposé à mainre reprise
dans cet hémicycle l'exécution de cette
loi a confirmé les craintes que nous
avions exprimé en commission mixte
paritaire de manière générale les
investissements n'ont malheureusement
pas suivi et la régénération du réseau
ferroviaire n'a pas encore eu lieu après
4 ans et plusieurs annonces du président
de la République non suivi des faits
nous devons ce texte à une initiative
parlementaire du président en
l'occurrence de la commission
aménagement du territoire développement
durable de l'Assemblée nationale
Jean-Marc zuli que je salue amicalement
la mise en place des services express
régionaux métropolitains est réclamé par
les élus locaux depuis de nombreuses
années dans la plupart des métropoles
les projets existent mais peennent à se
mettre en place en novembre 2019
Jean-Baptiste dbari affirmé dans ce même
hémicycle en matière ferroviaire il
s'agit de doter les métropoles de
liaison transversales rapid fréquentes
et interconnecté à l'image du réseau
express régional en
Île-de-France la présente proposition de
loi va plus loin car si les CERMES
s'appuient sur le renforcement des
dessertes ferroviaires il s'agit avant
tout d'offrir aux usagers une offre
multimodale de transport collectif
public une offre multimodale qui va
intégrer plusieurs modes de transport
tels que le covoiturage l'autopartage ou
encore les réseaux cyclables à
l'initiative de la Commission et notre
rapporteur plutôt que d'interdire
contraindre et sanctionner donnons aux
usagers les moyens de préférer un mode
de transport collectif réduire les
inégalités et inscrire les territoires
et leurs usagers dans la transition
écologique c'est tout l'enjeu des
nouvelles mobilités la présente
proposition de loi doit permettre de
donner corps et de soutenir ces
initiatives locales c'est bien de cela
dont il s'agit accompagner des projets
adaptés au territoire à cet égard je
remercie l'excellent rapporteur philippe
Tabarot par ailleurs c'est important de
le souligner membre du conseil
d'administration de la fit et du Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures les
CERMES doivent être je le cite être
pensés par et pour les territoires lors
de son audition le président du
directoire de la Société du Grand Paris
nous l'a confirmé les projets de cerme
ne se développeront pas sans
l'engagement conjoint et constant des
collectivités territoriales concernées
aussi à l'initiative de notre rapporteur
nous avons avec mes collègues membres de
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
notamment souhaité
inclure une consultation systématique
des mires et des départements en
amont ainsi que simplifier les
procédures et renforcer le rôle de la
région nous espérons que le Gouvernement
soutiendra ces modifications qui
participeront j'en suis certain au
succès des projets le texte transforme
la Société du Grand Paris en société des
grands projets lui en confi la maîtrise
d'ouvrage il est rassurant que
l'ensemble du territoire puisse
bénéficier de l'expertise de cette
société
qui a conduit qui conduit le chantier du
Grand Paris Express chantier pharaonique
ça a été évoqué qui rappelons-le a été
primé par l'Université de Harvard en
début
d'année pour autant les projets qui
seront déclinés dans les territoires ne
vont pas bénéficier des mêmes facilités
infrastructures que le Grand Paris
Express le Président nous l'a confirmé
il n'y a pas de réplicabilité du modèle
économique soyons le fide si les projets
initiés par les élus locaux
n'aboutissent pas c'est bien souvent en
raison d'un manque de financement
plusieurs pistes ont bien été évoquées
emprunt fiscalité appropriété
appropriation foncière tout cela pouvant
être mixé évidemment mais la question
n'est pas tranchée ce qui est certain
c'est que l'État devra prendre sa part
sauf à aggraver les inégalités
territoriales les CERMES ne peuvent pas
concentrer l'ensemble des finances
locales dédiées au transport et la
mobilité à l'instar de ce qui s'est
produit avec le TGV dans le cadre de la
présente proposition de loi le président
de la République s'est engagé sur une
première enveloppe de 760 millions
d'euros entre 700 et 800 selon euh les
organisateurs ou dédié à la réalisation
de 13 projets de RR c'était leur nom
métropolitain à comparé aux 2,6
milliards prévus dans la loi
d'orientation des mobilités avec une
prise en charge de l'État c'est ce qui
était intégré à hauteur d'1,3 milliards
cette somme semble très éloignée des 13
milliards d' chiffré en juillet 2022 par
Jean-Pierre farandou pour la mise en
place de C mêm Erer devenu Serme dans 13
métropole elle est encore bien plus du
budget du Grand Paris Express passé de
20 milliards d'euros à son lancement en
2010 à plus de 36 aujourd'hui tout cela
nous laisse évidemment interrogatif en
conséquence nous appelons comme le le
rapporteur le souhaite de nos vux
l'organisation d'une conférence
nationale de financement sur les CERMES
d'ici au 30 juin 2024 et attendant du
gouvernement qu'il donne les moyens au
CERMES d'exister ainsi modifié et avec
des réserves évidemment sur le volet du
financement le groupe les républicain
soutiendra cette proposition de loi
merci chers collègues et la parole est
donc maintenant à monsieur Simon hna du
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain pour 3
minutes madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur chers collègues dans la
continuité du rapport de notre collègue
philippe Tabarot dont je tiens à mon
tour à saluer la qualité du travail et
de l'écoute nous sommes évidemment tous
d'accord pour reconnaître qu'un choc
d'offre en faveur des transports
collectifs autour des métropole est
nécessaire pour autant comme l'a rappelé
Olivier Jacquin nous ne saurions nous en
contenter et c'est pourquoi nous
proposerons de rebatiser les CMEs en
services express régionaux de mobilité
en effet qu'il s'agisse de enjeu
écologique avec l'objectif dans le
secteur des transports de 28 % de
décarbonation à l'horizon 2030 par
rapport à 2015 ou encore des enjeux
territoriaux et sociaux dans le contexte
d'inflation forte et de renchirissement
très net des prix de l'énergie la
massification des transports collectifs
y compris sur la partie ferroviaire
constitue désormais un impératif
politique qui ne doit oublier aucun
territoire nous le savons bien et les
travaux de notre commission l'ont
rappelé avec insistance
le nerf de cette bataille capitale pour
rendre toujours plus accessibles les
mobilités décarbonés est avant tout
financier or sur ce sujet comme sur
beaucoup d'autres il y a malheureusement
monsieur le ministre loin de la coupe
des promesses aux lèvres de la réalité
entre l'annonce des 100 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2040 pour la nouvelle
donne ferroviaire et les 800 millions
d'euros pour les CERMES sans oublier les
besoins de régénération d'un réseau
ferroviaire particulièrement dégradé le
fossé est béant sur les CERMES ça a déjà
été dit nous sommes sur sur les 5
prochaines années à à peine 10 % de
l'effort en intégrant les financements
des régions le rapport de l'Autorité de
régulation des transports de juillet
2023 est par ailleurs particulièrement
inquiétant sur l'avenir de notre réseau
ferroviaire le président par intérim
notre ancien collègue Philippe Richer
écrit ainsi le maintien des trajectoires
d'investissement actuel tel que prévu
par le contrat de performance 2021-2030
entraînerait inévitablement le
gestionnaire d'infrastructure dans une
spirale de popérisation industrielle des
dépenses de régénér qui décroissent
depuis 2016 inférieur de 25 %
préconisation une concentration des
moyens sur le réseau structurant le plus
circulé tout cela préfigure une néfaste
archipelllisation du réseau et une
aggravation des disparités territoriales
pour cela nous serons donc vigilant à ce
que le déploiement des CERMES n'absorbe
pas tous les financements et ne se fasse
pas au détriment de l'indispensable
modernisation du
réseau si nous voulons être
collectivement à la hauteur des défis de
la régénération et du développement des
mobilités des carbon pour lesquels le
ferroviaire et l'épine dorsal nous
devons en effet d'urgence revoir un
système de financement des mobilités à
bout de souffle avec des financements de
l'État véritablement à la hauteur des
besoins monsieur le ministre en
investissement et en fonctionnement avec
une refonte du versement mobilité
additionnelle et des recettes fiscales
dédiées et sur le VMA la suppression du
plafonnement un VMA différencié en
fonction des projets et des bassins de
mobilité afin de permettre des
développements d'offres de transport
multimodal ciblé par territoire vous
avez pris l'engagement d'avancer sur ce
dossier monsieur le ministre notamment
dans le cadre du CP avec la région
Bretagne nous compons donc sur votre
mobilisation car cette réforme est
attendue avec impatience par de
nombreusesor autorités pardon
organisatrices de la mobilité quoi qu'il
en soit le texte de la commission
comprend de nombreuses avancées qui vont
dans le bon sens nous voterons donc ce
texte je vous remercie merci beaucoup
chers collègues la discussion générale
est clause monsieur monsieur le ministre
quelques mots avant de passer à la
discussion du texte de la commission
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
quelques mots rapides je vous rassure je
ne serai pas trop long mais sans revenir
sur tous les points quelques éléments
qui sont récurrents dans les différentes
interventions d'abord même si ça n'est
pas l'objet de cette proposition de loi
du débat de cet après-midi sur la
question des financements j'entends un
certain nombre d'interrogations sur
l'investissement global dans le
ferroviaire je ne détaillerai pas
intégralement nous aurons l'occasion de
parler dans cadre du débat budgétaire de
ces questions dans quelques semaines
mais c'est important de dire je voudrais
pas laisser s'installer l'idée ou le
sentiment qu'il n'y aurait pas
d'investissement à la hauteur des enjeux
qui se déploieraient dans le ferroviaire
notamment depuis un an et depuis que je
suis venu présenter pour ce qui me
concerne mon premier budget devant le
Sénat je ne ferai pas la liste complète
mais quelques exemples rapides sur le
ferroviaire en particulier CP monsieur
le sénateur hna vous citiez l'exemple de
Région Bretagne je crois que le
président chîn etgard ne me démand
tirait pas en disant qu'il a entre les
mains un bon Contrat de Plan Etat Région
nous avons augmenté de 50 % les crédits
annuels consacrés au mobilité dans les
mandats que nous sommes en train de
déployer et de négocier avec chacune des
régions avec un effort qui est cohérent
et siblé parfois c'est d'ailleurs
critiqué parce que c'est un choix
courageux nous réduisons en effet la
part consacrée aux routes
significativement mais pour augmenter
massivement y compris pour faire place à
ces fameux 800 millions d'euros la part
consacrée au ferroviaires et au
transport publics aprs en 2 tiers de
chacun des mandats adressés par la
première ministre à nos préfets de
région pour discuter avec les prés de
région donc c'est un effort conséquent
le réseau ferroviaire nous aurons
l'occasion d'en discuter et de le
matérialiser nous avons fait un effort
important l'an dernier nous allons faire
une marche massive supplémentaire dès
l'an prochain et c'est un engagement qui
sera je vous rassure gravé dans le
marbre de la première ministre présenté
sur le fondement du rapport du coi
d'augmenter de 50 % d'ici 2027 les
crédits annuels consacrés à notre réseau
ferroviaire car oui en effet vous l'avez
dit dit sur les différents bans dans les
différentes interventions le point de
faiblesse français en matière de
ferroviaire c'est le réseau et l'âge du
réseau on réinvestit je regrette que ce
n'ait pas été fait plus tôt mais nous
réinvestissons massivement je ne cherche
pas la polémique mais ce sont des
chiffres vérifiables bon ensuite sur les
fameux 700 millions d'euros devenu 800
vous montre le chiffre exact il est 767
millions d'euros et c'est le chiffre qui
est en entrée de discussion je ne vrais
pas dire ça en bon budgétaire en entrée
de discussion avec chacune des régions
et mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
j'entends votre interpellation mais je
me permets de la répercuter aussi
certains les connaissent personnellement
aux représentants des régions j'aimerais
déjà que les 767 millions d'euros vous
me permettrez de les arrondir à 800 qui
augmenteront peut-être un petit peu en
cours de négociation soit avec en face
des crédits similaires de la part des
régions je pense que ce sera le cas
j'espère que ce sera le cas mais si on
additionne les deux et donc c'est un
effort conjoint vous m'aurez compris que
nous devons porter ce fera ce sera déjà
plus d'un milillard 500 millions d'euros
pour une première étape j'y insiste et
c'est ensuite sur le fondement de la loi
qu'on discute ce soir que les plans de
financement sererme par sererme seront
présentés et à ce moment-là vous pourrez
d'ailleurs le vérifier en toute
transparence il faudra évidemment que
l'État souhaite au rendez-vous comme il
faudra que les collectivités soitent au
rendez-vous et comme pour ceux qui le
souhaitent pour les collectivités qui le
souhaitent des ressources fiscales
dédiées ce n'est pas une obligation
c'est une faculté pourront être
mobilisés c'est là que nous verrons
évidemment le coût et le plan de
financement et d'investissement de
chacun de ces services express régionaux
métropolitains mais admettez que pour
une politique qui se met en place et qui
commence 800 millions d'euros en
l'entrée de négociation c'est un ticket
d'entrée qui est pas totalement indécent
et il va augmenter il va être matché si
je peux le dire en mauvais français par
les régions je l'espère bien et il va
être ensuite affiné en cours de
déploiement de ces services express
régionaux métropolitains je rappelle
qu'on parle en plus de la première étape
2023- 20027 et pour beaucoup de projets
ce sera une phase d'étude je l'espère
faire de travaux aussi mais d'abord
d'études donc on ne parle pas de sommes
qui sont ridicules j insiste loin de là
avec un engagement très clair de l'État
dont j'attends qu'il
soit adressé avec un montant
correspondant et similaire de la part
des collectivités mais je suis confiant
sur ce point les négociations montrent
que cela est la direction prise voilà et
donc nous irons ensuite plus loin je
veux pas vraiment je vraiment pas
laisser s'installer l'idée que on
mettrait quelques cacahuètes sur les
services express régionaux
métropolitains ça fait cher la cacahuète
donc c'est quand même de l'argent
important qui est indicatif je l'ai dit
pas au sens où je néglige ses montants
mais au sens où par définition puisque
ces montants viennent des territoires
vers l'état et ces projets sont portés
par les collectivités soumis à
l'approbation de l'État c'est ensuite
partir du 1er semestre 2024 sans doute
que l'on définira et détaillera les
plans de financement l'État sera au
rendez-vous mais évidemment il faut que
les collectivités soiit aussi
rendez-vous et il faut aussi ce sera
encore une fois volontaire au cas par
cas que l'on ne s'interdise pas les
ressources fiscales dédié et affecté on
l'a fait pour laass du Grand Paris ça
peut être une solution pas forcé mais
possible pour différents projet de
service express régionau métropolitain
je vouis apporter ces quelques
précisions merci Monsieur le Ministre
bien nous allons donc passer à la
discussion du texte de la commission je
suis saisie à l'article premer d'une
parole sur article par Madame Denise SAÉ
pour 2 minutes s'il vous plaît je vous
en prie ma cherre collègue madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre messieur
le rapporteur et le président de la
commission mes ch collègues si les
Français sont prêts à réduire leur
recours à la voiture encore faut-il que
nous leur proposions des alternatives
pratiques et acceptables la présente
proposition de loi y répond en prévoyant
la création de servicees express
régionaux métropolitains ceux-ci ont en
effet la double ambition de proposer des
services de transport collectif qui
faciliteront la vie de nos concitoyens
tout en permettant d'accentuer la
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre d'un secteur des transports qui
en aimé encore beaucoup je tiens
également à saluer le travail de fond
sur ce texte de notre collègue
rapporteur philippe Tabarot ainsi que de
celui celui de mes collègu de la
commission du développement durable ils
ont permis de l'enrichir de manière
significative rien que sur l'article 1er
leurs amendements ont permis d'insister
sur l'importance de promouvoir une offre
de mobilité multimodèle ils ont aussi
rappelé la nécessité de penser les
CERMES à partir des territoire en
incluant autant que possible les
collectivités en amont de leur
déploiement je me réjouis enfin que le
gouvernement mette un coup
d'accélérateur sur ses services dans le
siège des annonces récentes du président
de la République je compte sur vous
monsieur le ministre pour que l'État
soit au rendez-vous ces projets sont
attendus avec impatience dans beaucoup
de métropoles mais aussi bien au-delà
dans les Pyrénées Atlantiques par
exemple le projet de RER pyrénéen
apporterait beaucoup car les dessertes
ferroviaires sont aujourd'hui de piètre
qualité avec à la fois peu de train et
des retards fréquents ce texte constitue
sans doute je l'espère un bon début pour
y remédier je vous remercie merci
beaucoup chers collègues bien nous
continuons par deux amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement 28 monsieur Jacquin le
présente merci madame la Présidente par
ce tout premier amendement nous
proposons simplement de renommer ce
texte en lui enlevant le qualificatif de
métropolitain pour le remplacer par
service express régionaux de mobilité il
faut le comprendre comme un point
d'enthousiasme de notre part par rapport
aux logiqu de mobilité du quotidien le
texte a été bien amélioré par la
Commission en conjuguant intermodalité
et multimodalité sur base ferroviaire et
routière essentiellement et euh il nous
semble que cette proposition permettrait
d'améliorer son acceptation car si le S
métropolitain pourrait encore accentuer
la fracture territoriale le S mobilité
vise au contraire à généraliser le
concept de densification et à rendre ces
services de mobilité accessies à